Hi.
My name is Andrei Mouravski
from the Dart team.
And I'm here to tell you how the
Dart project can help you
become a better developer, and
the tools that are available
for Dart developers to
make better code.
The Dart project is different
from other web development,
because we have a lot of tools
included in the SDK that you
can get everything, batteries
included.
Traditional web development is
scattered, and you have to
find your own package manager,
and you have to work with a
bunch of different tools that
don't really integrate well.
But the great thing about Dart
is that it's very toolable.
You can get started with
Dart by going to
dartlang.org/tools, where you
can download the SDK and the
editor, which we'll be using
for most of this talk.
The editor has all of the tools
that you need to write,
edit, test, document, analyze,
publish, and deploy your
applications to the world.
Something about me is that
people tell me that I'm too
timid, and I have a problem
where people don't take me
seriously on the internet.
So I want to build a Dart
application that can help me
be more persuasive on message
boards, comment threads.
So let's go make something
that will help.
Let's make an argument clinic
app that helps you become a
better speaker.
So we're going to build
this in several parts.
We're going to make a text
enhancer that takes your text
and turns it into something
better.
We'll write the unit tests
so we know it works.
We'll have documentation so
that we can use it in the
future, and others
can use our code.
And then we'll put it together
into a web app, and then share
it with the world.
So let's begin by building the
library text enhancer.
So this is the Dart Editor.
It was built as a plug-in on top
of Eclipse, but it is its
own separate editor.
And it has many useful features
like auto-complete
and refactoring that
I will show you.
So this library takes code and
turns it into uppercase so
your comments are
more persuasive.
But what if we want to change
this code later?
We have this quiet
text.toUpperCase.
And maybe I want to change how
I want to enhance text.
So let's refactor this in one
step so that we can have it
individually.
I could highlight text
and right click.
Click Extract Method, which
pops open a dialogue.
And here, this will let me
extract a method and rename
it, and have it as a
separate method.
So let's call this something
persuasive.
So now you see that we have
a new method that was
added to the file.
And the previous instance of
that code was replaced here
with the new call
to the method.
So how do I know my code is
doing what I want, if it's
really enhancing my text?
Well, we would use
a unit test.
But where would I get
a unit test library?
The pub package manager is
available from the Dart SDK.
And it exists as a service and
a tool that you can use to
share, use, and distribute
packages, which are
bunches of Dart code.
Pub.dartlang.org is a great
place you can go to check out
all the different packages
that are available.
There are packages for
everything from servers to
database connectors to
task runners, which
are all worth using.
The entry point to any package
is a file called pubspec.yaml.
And this is a file that
describes your
application or package.
And it also lists the
dependencies that your package
depends on.
So let's take a look at that.
The Dart editor has a handy
pubspec editor so that you can
edit the fields in
an easy fashion.
Here you see that I have the
name of the package, the
author of the version,
and the description.
And we're going to
add a dependency.
So I know that there is a
great pub package called
unittest, so I'm going to import
that by clicking the
Add Dependency button.
So this will just say that the
unit test package is a
dependency for your
own package.
We click Pub Install from here
or from the Tools menu to
install all the dependencies.
So this populates the packages
folder with all the packages
that we depend on.
So you see that there is this
meta package which was
included even though it's not
one of our dependencies.
Transitive dependencies
are also
included in your own package.
So unit test depends on meta,
which is added to your own
package so that the unit task
can function properly.
Let's go to one of our tests.
So here we have a simple test
to check if the shout method
does what we think
it's going to do.
But you see that there are these
warnings on the side
that the test function
is not defined.
We need to import the test
library into our Dart file so
we can use it.
And you do that by using
the package:import.
So this will import the unit
test package, which cleared up
all the warnings for test.
However, there's another warning
here, which says that
the shout is not defined.
Even though we're in the same
package, you still need to
include all of the Dart files,
the individual dependencies--
in this case the
shoutify file.
And you import that the
same way as you
would any other package.
So now you see that the
warning went away now.
But I forgot a semicolon.
And the Dart editor will tell
you any time you forget
something like this.
It will highlight errors.
So it expected to find
a semicolon.
So we're going to add a
semicolon and save.
And now this code should work.
You can test that the code
works by hitting the Run
button up here, or using
Control-R or
Command-R to run it.
So let's run it and see
what the output is.
The unit tests all passed,
as you see here,
and everything succeeded.
So what happens if a
unit tests fails?
Let's change this to from "a
little mouse" to "a little
moose." And this is going to
fail because we changed how
the test runs.
But let's see what actually
is happening.
In the Dart editor, you can
set a breakpoint to pause
execution of the code by right
clicking in the margin and
hitting Toggle Breakpoint.
So now when we hit Run, the unit
test library has paused.
And you can see the stack trace
of the current execution.
And you see that the loud text
is different from what we
expect it to be.
And so this test will fail.
The debugger lets you step into
code and step over code,
just like a debugger in other
IDEs, so that you
can examine the code.
And it'll give you the values
of any of the local and
top-level variables.
So let's stop debugging
and click Resume.
And you see that our tests
failed, and they printed out
all sorts of unhappy messages.
And you see the failure
up here.
Let's take out this breakpoint
and move on.
So we have these unit tests.
But how do we know if our code
is going to be stable, or if
other people try to depend on
the shoutify library, whether
they can be assured that
the code works?
Or, for that matter, what
happens if one of our
dependencies stops working?
What if unit test has a breaking
change and we need to
change things?
Well, for this we have
drone.io, which is a
continuous integration service
that monitors your GitHub
repository or code.google
repository or BitBucket.
And whenever it detects a change
in your repository or
in a repository of one of your
dependencies, or if one of
your dependencies is changed,
then it will rerun all of your
tests and then submit to you a
notification of whether it
passed or failed.
So let's try that.
So right now I have
a failing test.
And previously, I had
a passing test.
So let's go to commit all
the changes I have now.
And I'm going to push
this repository, and
we'll see what happens.
I'm switching over
to drone.io.
And my push is still
happening.
But now that it is finished
pushing, you see that on
drone.io, the build has
already started.
We can click into it.
And quickly enough, it shows
that our build failed.
This is also available as a
badge that you can embed into
a repository or as a dynamic
png, which I have on the
package here.
So it used to be passing, but
if we refresh, you see that
it's failing.
So anybody that goes to
pub.dartlang.org into your
package can see that your latest
tests are not passing.
So they might not want
to use your package.
Let's go back and fix that.
And we won't worry about
pushing it again.
So to maintain a good package,
you probably want to have good
documentation.
Documentation is sort
of like flossing.
It's something that you don't
always want to do, but you'll
really thank yourself
later if you do it.
Documentation in Dart
looks like this.
There are two forms of
documentation comments.
There is the /** model,
which lets you
do multi-line comments.
And then there's the ///, which
lets you do single line
comments, or you can chain a
couple of /// comments to have
a multi-line comment.
And once you add documentation,
your
documentation will look
something like this.
So it will look like the API
documentation for Dart itself,
which you can see here.
So api.dartlang.org is a great
resource for seeing all of the
packaged libraries that
come with Dart, and
seeing how they work.
So now that we have
documentation and we have unit
tests, we might want
to publish our app.
So it's going to look like it's
failing, but we still
want to get our new
code up on pub.
The way that you do this
is by using pub itself
to publish the app.
You can do this in several ways,
but one way is to go
back to your pubspec.
And there's a button next to
the Pub Install button that
says publish to Publish
to Pub.
You click on this, then a
dialogue will ask you if you
really want to publish this.
And I want to really enable
people to be heard on the
internet in their comments and
threads and, really, when they
have important things to say.
So let's publish this.
So this is going to go through
the process of
publishing to pub.
And you see that it was
uploaded successfully.
If we go back to pub,
we see that
our version has increased.
So our latest package is already
on pub, and other
people can start using it.
So now that we are done with
that, how about we go back to
our web app.
So what is our web app going
to look like to begin with?
So this is what I
built before.
And right now it doesn't
really do anything.
Right now, you can edit some
text, and click a button.
But it doesn't do anything.
It doesn't really make my
message any more clear.
So let's do that by modifying
this code.
We can go to the Dart file I
have for this application.
And you see here that on
a click, it updates the
value of the text.
We want to increase the volume
of our message, so we need to
use the shout.
Here we can just modify the text
to be shout(text), which
is how our method works.
And we already know it works
because of the unit tests.
However, we don't have
this test included.
You could try to import
it like this.
But this isn't going to work,
because this is a different
application, and it
doesn't know about
the shoutify library.
So we go to the pubspec
for this library.
And we add it as a dependency
just like we did with unit
test, except now we have
our own package that
we can depend on.
So we run Pub Install to get
everything up and running.
And we go back here.
And we save again.
And now everything is working.
So now we can deploy
this to the web.
One tool that you have available
is Dartium, which is
a development browser that
has the Dart virtual
machine built in.
To run it, you right click on
your main Dart or HTML file,
and they you say
Run In Dartium.
However, one thing that's great
about having the VM
included is that you can debug
your application right from
the Dart editor.
So let's Toggle Breakpoint right
here, just like we did
earlier, and right click Run In
Dartium, which will run our
new application.
So let's see what happens.
So let's say "I disagree with
you," which is lackluster.
Click here, and it clearly makes
your message pop more.
Let me try this again.
To get the debugging, I needed
to run Dartium from the HTML
file, which I did not.
And so now I am waiting for
the Dartium to load so
I could debug it.
But as it is not loading, I am
going to show you how else you
can deploy your Dart
applications.
There is a common myth that goes
a little bit like this.
But Dart is not just
for Chrome.
It runs in all modern web
browsers using a compiler
called dart2js, which
converts Dart code
into JavaScript code.
We have been making a lot of
progress and many improvements
in reducing the size of the
JavaScript code that's
generated from Dart code.
So if after you minify using
dart2js and run gzip on your
web server, you can reduce the
size of your JavaScript code
to something really manageable
and deploy it everywhere.
However, you're not just
writing in JavaScript.
You have the full complement
of Dart tools, and you have
the type system, and you have
the package manager--
all of this stuff included which
you wouldn't get with
JavaScript.
So let's see what this looks
like in different browsers.
So to run in JavaScript,
you right click
again on the HTML file.
And you click Run
As JavaScript.
And this will create
the JavaScript
version of your code.
So you see here that when you
click on the button, you see
that it works.
Something else you can do.
In browsers that support source
maps, you can go into
the actual Dart file from the
developer tools, and debug it
straight from the browser,
from Dart in this case.
So here I could set
a breakpoint in
the developer tools.
And now when I click on this
button, it actually pauses the
execution of the
JavaScript app.
But I'm still looking
at the Dart code.
So this makes it very easy to
debug your applications in
different browsers where there
are source maps available.
And this is included
automatically whenever you
compile the dart2js.
So just to show you that we
mean business, here is the
same application in Firefox--
works as you would imagine.
And here it is Internet
Explorer.
And I forgot to refresh.
And here it works perfectly.
So let's go back and see
what else we could do.
So I've shown you how to build,
test, deploy, and
document this package.
But maybe you're not too
interested in working in the
Dart editor.
Or maybe you want to SSH into
a machine where you're more
comfortable working.
Or maybe you have a different
text editor.
Well I'm happy to say that all
of the tools that I've shown
you-- dart2js, the documentation
generator, pub--
are all available on
the command line.
So here I could do
pub install.
And if I was in the
right directory
it would have worked.
I do pub install.
And it does the same thing.
It resolves all dependencies
and installs them.
You do the same thing with
dart2js, the Dart
documentation tool--
all of this can run from
the command line.
But we also have support for
a full complement of text
editors and IDEs like Eclipse
and WebStorm, which have
really great integration.
But I want to show you something
that we have fairly
recently is our Sublime
integration.
So you can install the Dart
plug-in for Sublime using the
package control plug-in.
And it's as simple as doing
Package Control, Install
Package, and then Dart.
And fairly quickly, your package
will be installed.
And then you could set
syntax to Dart.
And then your Dart code will
be syntax highlighted.
From here, you could also
do pub install.
You can also run the analyzer,
which will tell you about any
errors you have in your code.
For example, if I remove this
semicolon and I run the
analyzer, then it will tell
me that there is a missing
semicolon right here
in Sublime.
So you can keep your
productivity high with the
editor that you're used to.
There's way more tools than I
could possibly go into in this
short amount of time.
But here a couple of libraries
that are available in pub.
There's really excellent
task runners.
The web UI library is great
for building modern user
interfaces with a model
view, whatever model.
There is a great build
pack for Heroku.
So if you have a server-side
application, you could push it
to Heroku in one step and have
your application live.
And there's way more.
And more is coming
out all the time.
So if we go back to the argument
clinic and see if we
accomplished everything we
wanted to, we saw that we were
able to be more persuasive
on the internet.
And we made it possible for
other people to use our
application by sharing it
as a web app and as
a package on pub.
So perhaps if somebody wants
to mash up a text enhancer
with some social network,
they could do so
using the APIs provided.
And I think I've made the
world a little better by
making your comments
more persuasive.
Thank you for listening
to this talk.
If you want to find out more
about Dart, you can go to
dartlang.org.
There we have a full complement
of videos,
articles, documentation,
tutorials, mailing lists.
You can also catch us on the
Google+ community Dartisans.
And most of all, I want you to
go out and be productive, and
give it what for.
Thanks.